Stop Saying, from BBC Learning English dot com.
Hi, I'm Sugah and I come from Japan.
When someone asks me how I am, I usually say 'I'm good', but is this wrong? Should I stop saying it?
Hi, Tim here! You're right: people often use 'good'
in this way, with a verb. Normally we think of
'good' as an adjective and 'well' as an adverb,
so you'd expect to hear things like:
Hi Tim, how are you?
I'm well, thanks.
So why do we sooften hear things like:
How are you?
I'm good. Thanks, Tim.
It's because with some verbs, which
we sometimes call 'link verbs', it's okay to use
'good' in this way. These include 'be', 'seem',
'appear', 'look', 'taste', 'smell', 'sound', and 'feel'.
He smells good.
He looks good.
But I hear it in other placestoo. For example, in the movie, I heard, "He cooksreal good".
Ah, well, this is an example of language
changing. In some varieties of English, for example
US English, adjectives are occasionally used when
we would use an adverb in British English. Compare these:
He sings pretty bad.
He sings prettybadly.
That's real good.
That's really good. But that accent is really bad.
Thanks Tim, thatexplanation was real good, but you sing prettybad.
How do you know that?
Yeah, on second thoughts, maybe I shouldn't sing. Best keep the day job. Bye!